[Music]
definitely answer this does god have
people in babylon and who are those
people
yes well repetition is good so let's
deal with that again but let me pray
first father as we continue please
direct all of our minds i pray put your
words literally in my mouth your ideas
in my mind of the humility of christ in
my heart in jesus name i pray amen
yes god has people in babylon he does
jesus said in john chapter 10 for verse
other sheep i have which are not of this
fold
them also i must bring now there's
something called sheep stealing which
all pastors hey don't take my members
but jesus i hate to say jesus sheep
steal he doesn't steal but christ came
to bring people out of false systems he
said look i have
she in other foals i've got to bring
them of course he brings them with us
said the lord of the sheep i have which
are not of this fall and someone
listening to me may come under that
description
them also i must bring and they shall
hear my voice now wait a minute
what is the voice of god this is the
voice of god right here they shall hear
my voice and they shall be one fold and
one shepherd so yes and the powerful cry
of revelation 18 4
come out to her my people that you be
not partakers of her sins and that you
receive not of her plagues for her sins
have reached unto heaven and god has
remembered her iniquities and when god
remembers it means he's about to act and
so we uh god has people in babylon but
the message of revelation 46-12 will
bring them out and that message is
amplified by the message of revelation
18 1-5 god has people and when people
hear the message they will come i got a
text last week from a lady she said i've
been listening to your messages and i've
accepted the truth i've become assembly
advocates i got a text from a lady in
nigeria she said i've been listening to
your messages i want to how can i become
a senator i wanted to obey god and from
time to time i get messages like that
because when the truth touches the heart
of a sincere person the person may not
know everything but even a little pebble
of truth when it touches a sensei heart
it leads an impression and that person
is moved by god's spirit to act
so god has people in babylon and they
will come up also let me give you the
sad side of that god has people in his
church who will leave
because when we read from first timothy
four verse one now the spirit speaks
especially in the latter time some shall
depart from the faith there'll be a
going and coming a going and coming
but you know paul tells us in the second
thessalonians two verse three let no man
deceive you by any means for this for
that's that they shall not come except
they come are falling away first they'll
be they'll be uh um direction movement
in two directions people leaving truth
and people coming to truth my listening
friend wherever you are be part of the
movement toward truth because to leave
truth is to leave life to live truth is
to leave god and so god has people in
churches that disregard god by
disregarding his law he will call them
out and when they hear the word they
will come because my sheep know my voice
they may be in the long flock but they
know my voice when they hear it they'll
come
and what brings them the message
that's the voice of god today the
message
that's right that's right you're
adulterated it might just the law of god
get out of that church
even if it worships on sabbath if it
minimizes the law of god find another
church
this was a crime of the antediluvians
minimizing god's law this was the crime
of sodom and gomorrah minimizing god's
law this was a crime with babylon under
that nebuchadnezzar destroyed minimizing
god's law this is why the northern
kingdom went into captivity minimizing
god's law this is why new testament
battle was destroyed minimizing god's
law by minimizing the law giver it is
the minimizing the disregarding of the
law of god because the disregarded law
of god is to disregard the law given
jesus christ
no matter what else you may say
in vain do they worship me teaching for
doctor the commandments of men we have
the commandments of many commandments of
god if worshipping by the commandments
of men is useless then worshiping based
on god's commandment that is acceptable
to god simple reasoning
and god has people who realize have been
worshipping god ignorantly and falsely i
need to get out and find myself in a
system where the law of god is respected
christ is savior yes but he saves me
from breaking his law and he brings me
to the place where i
my testimony becomes i'd like to do thy
will or my god yet thy law is within my
heart
any system that undermines god's law
that's what it comes down to
satan's object of opposition has always
been god's
law that's what is take away the lord
the devil has no problem with you me or
anybody else take away the god law he
has no problem the law is what sticks in
his craw and that's why for hundreds of
years he's fought this battle and he
uses religious systems to advance his
cause
all right dr mccarthy next question
amen amen i'm tempted as you were
talking about the law and how vital it
is how it is to the core i'm thinking
about the human body that god created
and how the law is the foundation the
framework just like our bones the
skeleton structure everything is built
on the bones and if we destroy the bones
we destroy the tissue all right the law
is foundational
all right